so first of all thanks for having me
thanks for putting my name next to
Richard carps name in the same line
that's enough for me we are somewhat
intimate audience so let's just adjust
instead of feeling negative everybody to
make feel you know feel free to make it
more interactive I did kind of plan this
talk to be high level and somewhat broad
but feel free to kind of grill me on
questions I may not have slides for it
and also kind of a threat if you don't
do it there's a chance that Ellie will
ask a lot a lot of questions yes finally
you know we'll find out during the talk
I guess cool so what we're going to talk
about is this technology that's at the
back end of block chains and
cryptocurrencies and really what it's
about is this ability to keep a ledger
of you know your digital money your
payment you know the withdrawals and the
deposits the same one that you currently
have in the bank presumably most of you
don't have all of your worldly assets in
physical gold or in you know physical
cash presumably it is already digital in
some ledger but the difference is this
ledger is in some bank that you trust
and these banks these institutions are
centralized and because they're
centralised they've been somewhat
stagnated in the technology that they
Harbor not perhaps as efficient and
modernized as we would like them not a
lot of competition there's a lot of rent
that they extract out of their position
of centralization and so the idea is
that this technology will enable
decentralizing these Ledger's such that
we can open the platform for competition
more efficiency and you know far far
greater interoperability so what I'm
gonna do today is take you through this
journey of about four decades of the
technology behind this
that enables the decentralization of the
core of blockchains
so the journey starts here many of you
if not all of you perhaps know this work
and it's kind of a fascinating story
perhaps one of my favorites so this is
the work that was done in the late 70s
when NASA wanted to build a control
system for its avionics systems and for
spacecraft and they realized that there
could be false
there could be faulty hardware there
could be a sensor that has a faulty
reading and so they built their control
systems with three replicas of all of
their computers and sensors and a
paradigm which used voting of two out of
three especially if one sensor went bad
or some computer had a malfunction or a
bug or something like that then by
majority the other two would actually
drive the decision so this seems to make
sense right but they didn't stop at that
they went to the experts in the field a
group of scientists at SSRI
international and asked them to look at
this design and verify that it is
actually correct and will always be safe
and there's always going to be a right
decision and this is this is a an
artwork taken from the paper this this
group of scientists produced and the
rest is history again one of my favorite
story is what this group of scientists
showed is first of all the design was
not safe secondly they proved that it
could never be safe with three computers
in the settings and the hardware that
was available at the time so they proved
it was impossible and thirdly for good
measure they showed that with four
computers there is a solution and
produced the force the first solution
and the first algorithm that would
actually work and in these foundations
are the ones that we still carry till
today they also are coined the term
Byzantine failure to model these type of
failures or malfunctions that
cause these arbitrary behaviors and what
we say in this picture is exactly that
you know one of the components behaves
arbitrarily has a bad rating but it
doesn't stop there
it might actually tell one thing or send
a message over the wire with one bit to
one participant and something else to
another participant and this is what's
known as Byzantine failures and
Byzantine filtering systems till today
so fast forward to today's settings and
about 2012 Bitcoin gave essentially the
killer app for Byzantine fault tolerance
so this idea of maintaining a
decentralized ledger of payments in a
global currency is the killer app that
requires scalability and
decentralization in this lack of trust
in the participants but they did not
give a satisfying solution that could
actually scale for global needs and
could actually provide the serious
strong basis for really changing the way
we do financial services so this caused
institutions enterprises and even banks
and governments to again do the same
thing go to the experts and essentially
accelerate the interest and the
attention in this technology and
encourage and foster research and
advances that would bring this
technology to the scale and the the
seriousness that we needed today and so
if there's one message that you would
take away from the stock today is that
yes blockchain in the past few years has
really unlocked tremendous innovation
creativity originality and a lot a lot
of advances in the field and
specifically for the talks today I want
to go also a step beyond just hardening
and just strengthening the technology so
that it's more scalable and perhaps more
robust but also thinking about okay can
we go beyond the known impossibility and
resilience bounce so yes Breaking and
bypassing the
balance for resilience so this is the
spoiler and hopefully I'll deliver on
some of it later on the other takeaway
is that hey if you're in the Box trader
field then you probably have job
security for the next year or two to
work on these problems and so focusing
on this very problem of Byzantine fault
tolerance so decentralizing a log that
keeps the payments the his you know
payment history of transactions if you
look at the history if you do a brief
snapshot that the way it was developed
then initially it was presented as I
said in the setting of a control system
of three or four computers and the first
solution that was given was for
real-time networks and was meant really
for that type of scale for you know
three or four participants it took
almost a decade for the community to
develop the first solution that did not
rely on synchronous networks and that
was the DLSE
solution and that was not a practical
solution was mostly to show that it was
possible and he took another decades for
the community to develop the first
two-faced solution which was practical
and also named the practical solution
called pbft then for about a decade what
happened was what I call the last decade
of Byzantine fault tolerance where the
community kind of went the wrong wrong
track and looked for you know improved
practicality but actually with with a
flawed basis and then he took more than
a decade for this renewed interest
stemming from the blockchain world and
in the past four or five years we see
tremendous progress where all of these
solutions come together you know flawed
foundations or our problems in the
foundations were addressed and
scalability was driven all the way down
to
you know really scalable and really
practical solutions and this is a sort
of a briefing story and I'll go through
it in a little bit more detail in a few
more slides before I get there I want to
say this technology is is relevant it
has a compelling use case and at
Facebook / Calibra we've actually
announced a few months ago that we're
going to that we plan to launch a
platform that will drive financial
services and we'll bring to the world
digital currency that will allow
interoperable financial services and
payments over the trust firm and the
platform called Libre will be driven by
a blockchain obviously Facebook is not
the only one but this is a very
ambitious and real project with a grand
and important mission for enhancing the
way financial services and payments and
people use them in the world now Libre
is different from many of the other
blockchains out there in a number of
important ways Libre is a unit of
accounting that is backed by a reserve
the precise composition of the reserve
is still something that's being
determined but essentially it will be a
non fractional reserve which will have a
one-for-one backing for every unit of
currency in a basket of currencies or
you know the exact composition will be
determined that will be invested and
kept by the Liebherr association and
managed such that the unit of currency
will be a proxy for the reserve the
Libra blockchain itself is meant to be
interoperable and allows services to be
implemented on top of it and allow
transfers of Libra
among them now the Libra blockchain
itself is designed among initially the
founding members of the Libra
association in a way that decentralizes
the trust and such that no individual
member including Facebook a Libra which
is the you know designer and the the the
visionary behind this then of the no no
single member including Calibra will
have control so this is a decentralized
group of industries and of strong
participants that will together maintain
and operate this blockchain press room
over time the initial set of members may
grow and may open its participation as
through mechanisms that will on the one
hand allow dynamism and on the other
hand will continue maintaining the
guarantee of decentralization so this is
the of course
yeah so in fact kind of this slide is
the initial membership of the
association that was established exactly
two or three weeks ago it has as you
know 21 members and the current plan is
to launch the blockchain with we still
hope
about a hundred addition you know so
there will be additional members so the
initial participation will be fixed but
they're definitely going to be methods
that will allow additional members to
apply and to rotate their participation
both in the Association and in the
blockchain the exact details of them are
still you know subject of the entire
community's research as well as their
own and will be rolled out by lunchtime
so the those are great questions so the
association is first of all you know a
non-profit established in Switzerland
whose role is to govern both the
technology all the decisions about the
design as well as the decisions about
the basket and the investment of all the
reserve that backs this blockchain and
investment token that will be coupled
with this technology this is a this is
the role of the association now the
initial members of the Association the
plan is for them also to be the ones
that participate in the decentralized
distributed protocol and each one of
them will host and operate a single node
in this network that consists you know
that builds the blockchain platform down
the line these two might diverge in
certain ways the participation in the
blockchain might
become more automated but still governed
by the Libre Association I also want to
emphasize that as of three weeks ago
when the Libre Association has been
established anything that I can say
about our thoughts in calibra is subject
to final realization and consensus
decision by the Libre Association
Calibra is just one member at this point
out of 21 and later out of 100 yep yes
yes yes yes but I also want to mention
these are also participating companies
in the Libre Association and not just
nodes in the blockchain technology so
I'm a technology point of view the
scalability is planned to be suitable
for much higher scale and dynamism yep
so I can enter to some degree obviously
I'm not an economist I have been in the
blockchain field for a number of years
now and so I've learned a lot about
money through this process but I'm not
an expert in economics so what you're
asking is what is money and that's a
very good question and you know our
startled and Plato have their answers
and the Federal Reserve it's answer but
assuming that you have faith in money in
today's economies whether it's the
dollar in the u.s. whether it's Europe
in Europe
what Libra does is maintains a non
fractional reserve an investment of
whatever is used to buy libras in a bank
will not loan or use it in any
fractional way the way banks do so it's
not going to turn into a bank
it's a reserve and provide you a digital
representation a proxy of every unit
that's in the reserve to handle
digitally so a layman's answer that I
can give is think of it like a casino
chip you go you give a dollar you got a
chip that says one dollar and you know
if you think that a casino is stable
enough and will not go away and will
always have enough dollars in the cash
one-for-one against those chips that it
turns out you can always go back and the
guarantee that the Libra association
manifests gives they were not frac
yes so the the guarantees in The
Economist's terms is that it's non
fractional so not be used to loan back
and to gain interest on okay and yeah
and I think again these are expending
times this is David Marcus the head of
Libra in a deposition in front of the
Congress and I you know there are many
ways to look at this the way I look at
this is there's very very strong
interest very strong curiosity to catch
up with innovation and guarantee that
there's regulation and regulatory
oversight that protects our economy and
our society and at the same time not
stop innovation and you know there's
some hurdles and questions and concerns
and all sorts of interesting evolutions
that will go in the this process but a
lot of curiosity and at the end
innovation will win so I just want to
mention the distinction between Libra
which is both the Association and in the
technology and also the name of the
token that's going to be launched in
calibra which is the company that pays
my salary and also develops a custodial
wallet which will be one of the many
services that we expect to launch and to
make use of the platform and Libra the
wallet will be the service and the
business and the product that caliber
the company will operate yep
which keys so if you are going to be a
customer of the colibri wallet then
Calibra will establish an account for
you and will kyc you and on board you
and maintain keys for you but you will
have the option to use the services of
any other wallet it will launch on the
platform cool shifting gears back to
technology so all of this goes back to
the works of you know the foundations of
Byzantine fault tolerance so the nice
thing about computer science and science
in general is that we're able to take
this very very complex problem of
financial services and payments and so
forth and distill it to a very very
simple problem that if you solve it once
you can build all of this technology on
top of it and this is what you know the
Byzantine generals problem did for us so
the problem you know in one slide is
there's a group of participants we
typically denote their number n and we
assume that some of them are not trusted
or corrupt and the term that we use for
them are Byzantine and we usually denote
them by F you know that's the threshold
of the Byzantine participants and what
they want to do is reach agreement or
just a single bit zero one once you
solve that problem you can repeatedly
solve this problem and form an entire
block chain of blocks of transactions
and contents and values by solving this
basic core so to solve this basic core
let me spend kind of a few minutes to
give you sort of a consensus or
Byzantine fault tolerance 101 what you
need to know if you were the CTO of a
blockchain company and you need to make
some decisions and design the
architecture and the core of your
blockchain so we already know you know a
very simple problem that you need to
solve the next thing that you need to
ask yourself is what do you assume about
the network
so the original network of a spacecraft
was you know very small it was all in
the cockpit of a single spacecraft and
it was assumed that the communication
was reliable and timely and if you know
two computers were correct then every
message reached you know the other
computer in a known bounded time this is
what we call synchronous network and the
original solutions that was given under
this setting was safe under this
assumption in under this assumption the
original solution showed that you can
actually tolerate up to a minority of
the failures assuming digital signatures
assuming public cryptography or if you
don't assume public rafi and the setting
of the spacecraft did not have that then
you need to have more than or let me put
it around the other way around it most
third of the participants could be
Byzantine faulty and this is under the
assumption that the network is
synchronous no matter what you do these
are the known bounce also they showed
that under this setting if you have n
participants then you need in a worst
case scenario at least n synchronous
rounds to reach a solution using this
assumption of synchrony and there's a
lower bound that came much later that
you need at least a quadratic number of
messages to reach a solution so all
these are well known balance that were
given along the years and I've kind of
kind of discouraging when you think
about the N this number not as three or
four but as something that needs to grow
to tens of thousands or maybe even
millions of participants as parish
officer questions so in the original
setting didn't seem too bad but scaling
is a challenge now even more challenging
is when you start thinking about
decentralized settings where the network
may suffer periods
attacks or delays or disruptions or even
partitions as in a wide area settings
and doesn't have this reliable synchrony
guarantee and then the situation is even
worse so first of all the problem is
impossible to solve so is there anybody
in this very intimate audience that did
not know this simple fact oh good so I
have one one person that took something
out in stock so there's a well-known
classical impossibility that says that
under asynchronous settings let me say
this a little bit more precisely it's
not that it's impossible but there may
always be a very unlucky scenario in
which repeatedly messages are dropped
and delayed and prevent any algorithm
that you decide from reaching a decision
for arbitrarily long time most of the
time it can behave well but there's
probably always a very unlucky scenario
that will prevent convergence no matter
what you do you need you can be
resilient to it small just a third
faulty even if you have digital
signatures or no matter what and then
the question is how do you deal in
practice with this impossibility so the
most promising theoretical direction to
do it is to try to quantify this very
unlucky scenario in something that you
enforce in the algorithm and this is the
approach that been or introduced where
you introduce randomness into the
algorithm and flip coins and then this
allows you to reason and to analyze
about the you know the actual quantity
the actual probability of this unlucky
scenario and bound it so that it's very
unlikely to happen and you know it took
the community quite a long time in fact
only this year we introduced a solution
that using this randomized approach
would meet a similar
to the synchronous setting in particular
we'll have N squared communication and
until now until very recently most of
the protocols first of all has a
polynomials that was more than quadratic
and secondly were quite complex so for
the most part this was Theory land and
of course sure the order one expected
yes but all of these properties jointly
so N squared communication with the
truss to set up and order one expected
number of rounds this is something that
was only closed this past year they did
not give n squared communication back
then polynomial yes yes but not in
squared and for modest number n like
hundreds quadratic is potentially you
know feasible and to the three enter the
four is already you know just think of
it you know let's say it's a hundred
hundred participants like the Libra
Association no no it's no they're always
here is actually very small
oh yeah yeah so this is a very very
abbreviated history just highlighting
first of all the first groundbreaking
you know conceptual groundbreaking idea
that showed that you can use
randomization and then fast forward to
where we are today
so this is very very abbreviated this is
also not that so no no no intention to
kind of insult anybody in the
synchronous oh yeah yeah absolutely yeah
yes a trusted set up means that parties
are assigned keys that they you know
some some shared randomness or some
shared keys before they start that they
they all know of it of that they all
know of so some dealers some trusted
dealer hands keys to everybody not a
global certification authority but some
dealer that is setting up for this
particular set of end players shares
secret or shares a key among the
participants you can do it once and then
you can apply this solution again and
again again with a single trusted setup
but if you don't have that trusted set
up then there's no known solution with N
squared there are known solutions but
the best one is and to the five some
polynomial yep
it does not hold so order n-squared
communication holds for probabilistic it
also holds for synchronous setting and
that was shown actually in the recent
pod see for the synchronous setting I'm
not sure it holds for the synchronous
setting with randomization I think
that's still open I would have to check
no no but this is a lower he's talking
about the lower bound so he's asking
whether there's a lower bound of n
squared communication on on randomized
algorithms and yes
so I want to distinguish simply because
the normal assumption that we have in
all of these protocols is authenticated
channels point-to-point channels without
that there's very little we can do and
that already also requires some kind of
I don't know a global setup that's not
the assumption the assumption here is
that there's actually a dealer that
shares a secret or a key among these and
participants so not just a
point-to-point authenticated channels
that's the standard assumption no there
is so so these this upper bound does use
trust and setup and uses computational
crypto yep yeah and without
computational assumption what is the
best random evolution it's probably
those film when we call the old
solutions or yes but yes but I don't
think they solve it with order one
expected yeah I don't think you can
I'm very honored to be confused with in
Cali but this one is I used to be cool I
don't mind spending all the lecture on
this slide I mean so this is a very
abbreviated history of all synchronous
solutions all asynchronous solutions all
you know asynchronous randomized
solutions clearly not the topic of this
talk but it's very very abbreviated
history just to kind of the takeaway
message is to say this is a hard problem
and there's a lot of theory behind it
that is not satisfying for the kind of
use cases that we need and for good
reasons and there are lower bounds the
thing you can never do anything better
yeah but that's very theoretical I don't
know what you can do in a network that
you don't even know who you are talking
to and you can't distinguish you have
ports and you can only distinguish
between your left port and your right
door those are where we're in the
Internet and you have IP you know until
s on the internet and you know who
you're talking to
that's a very least yeah for sure
otherwise we're really in Theory land
how much how long should I plan this for
an hour starting at 4:30
4:15 or starting at 4 okay so I have a
yeah I'm gonna fast forward and not talk
a lot about what change to talk about
that's fine let me just very quickly say
what happens with practical solutions so
I wanted to give a very quick taste on
why this is a hard problem and that we
have solid foundations that indicate
some some resilience bounds but at the
same time we also have practical systems
that are built with Byzantine photons
and they take a different approach and
the approach that they take is to focus
on a model we call partial synchrony
which guarantees safety at all times and
waits for periods of synchrony to make
progress and kind of combines this async
on a synchronous approach and this is a
model that was introduced and
groundbreaking result by Dworkin chess
stockmeyer both for standard crash
failures and for these Byzantine
failures and the main value of the
solution was really to show that it's
possible to present a solution that
works in this approach and again it
always guarantees safety you never reach
conflicting decisions but you may go
through arbitrary of periods of time
where you know for the network doesn't
behave as you expect then your timing
out prematurely and not making any
progress the purpose of the solution was
not as a practical system design and in
fact it was polynomial with many many
rounds of communication and at the end
of the day acquired some synchrony in
order to make progress
it took the community 11 years for
Castro and Lascaux to introduce a
practical approach that focused on a
very kind of intuitive notion of leader
based scheme for solution the idea was
to go through some period of warm-up
where perhaps there are failures or
perhaps there are even premature
timeouts but eventually a stable leader
in the network one of the nodes in the
network will have stable communication
timely communication with everybody and
then it can repeatedly drive decisions
very very efficiently just by proposing
the decision and having everybody accept
that and that was the pbft practical be
bft approach and those of you were at
simons
a couple of weeks ago would have had the
you know the privilege of hearing
Barbara Liskov talk about the context in
which this solution emerged so the
solution is practical in the sense that
it's very very fast and very simple once
a leader emerges it has quadratic
communication complexity in the common
case and every time the leader needs to
be replaced there's a quadratic
communication to replace the leader and
that can cascade in the worst case who
can cascade even under you know
synchronous and faultless conditions it
can cascade order and times so you get n
cubed communication complexity until you
make progress so again this is practical
for small ends but not so practical for
very large ends so then our hot light L
introduces Eva
Levi's the last word in the dictionary
so they gave their protocol the last
word in the dictionary assuming this
would be the last word in Byzantine
fault-tolerance and what they did is
take pbft and edge to it a fast track
that was linear in the faultless common
mode where a leader and everybody was
fail free so they're really optimized
for the kind of best conditions and
under more adverse conditions they fall
back to pbft so N squared leader change
that could cascade and so forth
unfortunately this was also not a safe
protocol and this is something that
we've indicated the community once we
started looking for scalable solutions
for block chains and so it be aware with
with the team of researchers that I've
worked with we introduced a fix to their
approach and also combined it with you
know well-known methods in security
protocols where when a leader collects
identical votes identical of messages
from the network it uses threshold
crypto to combine these messages and
thereby drive the communication down
from and squared to linear and linear is
really the best you can hope for when
you want to drive any kind of agreement
the very least you have to do is send a
message about the decision to everybody
so the linear is really the best you can
hope for and in this solution called the
SPF T the common mode was linear but
leader replacements still inherited the
TLS and then the pbft and the Z's Eva
approach that is quadratic and again
that can that can cascade and cause n to
the three communication cost and so
finally the the date is wrong here but
last year we introduced a hot stuff
which is an approach that takes
these advances together and combines
them and produces a solution that has
linear communication in all these
scenarios both of the common mode and
the leader replacement and the other
nice thing about hot stuff is that you
would think that with all the other
advances and all this theory we came up
with a very very complex protocol with a
lot of corner faces and so forth but
actually this was a very simple protocol
in fact it's so simple that I've
attempted to put it on one slide but
since I'm so so so far behind schedule I
won't go through the details you can
actually explain this protocol in one
slide very simple very developer
friendly to implement and in fact Libre
is developing its core it's blocked in
core around this protocol as do other
companies
[Music]
this is what this is where we use
threshold crypto and combine and
aggregate signatures so we aggregate and
signatures into one and we never do this
counting so when we say n order n it's
really ordering its order in messages of
constant size
I mean constant up to the fact that you
have counters that are you know
theoretically not bounded but it is
constant oh yeah yes yes yep yes no
that's worst case by the way there's no
there's no randomization here this is
deterministic
there's no randomization here this is a
term deterministic protocol yeah yes
it's for the partially synchronicity it
doesn't use randomization to overcome an
asynchronous uses optimism it may go
through a period where you don't make
progress if the network is under attack
or you know go through these Ising
experience it's guarantees progress as
soon as a leader stable leader emerges
the same practical approaches PBF TMDLs
the same one is a Paxos the same one
that underlies wherever you keep your
mail in the clouds these days for
reliability for application all of these
mechanisms essentially use partial
synchrony this is the the approach that
underlies all replication know the
special crypto yeah that does have this
there's no randomization except you know
in determining keys but the guarantee is
probabilistic under the suitable
cryptographic assumptions the protocol
itself does not have any coin tossing
and does not use randomization to drive
a decision in all of these so one thing
that we've added when taking this
protocol to production is liveness and
[Music]
the original hotstuff technology there
was no explicit mechanism for driving
liveness and the native way of doing it
with the gain creep in quadratic
communication and in Libre this is done
with linear communication in the common
mode Mike
so the leader of every round suffers the
load of collecting messages combining
them for threshold ding and broadcasting
back but the leader rotates in each and
every round so unlike previous protocols
where leader replacement was this heavy
costly operation that he wanted to avoid
here this protocol looks like a block
train and it is much more like a block
chain in the sense that in every round
somebody becomes a leader proposes a
proposal and the next leader collects
votes and aggregates them and again
broadcasts a new proposal
so again if you actually want everybody
to learn the decision the very least you
have to pay ordering doesn't matter how
efficient the yeah so if you if you are
looking for mechanism where even the
leader of around does not incur you know
linear cost then there are actually
folks who are working on it there was a
nice talk at Simons last week by the
cello folks hello folks
I forgot his name but they were working
on implementation of hot stuff that does
the aggregation along a tree they call
it a bf tree and the t's PFT and tree
and very interesting mechanism and there
are others who are working on
aggregating along a and aggregation
overlay structure that also combines the
signatures gradually along the network
kind of incrementally so that there's no
single member that is tasked with
aggregating everything even across a
single round my own view is that the
way you scale to billions of users is or
billions of participants is probably
different
so right so I would do that I would
probably do that in protocol's like this
as a communication substrate so I would
say you know logically I want to
broadcast a message to everybody doesn't
mean I actually have to send a
point-to-point TCP message to each and
everyone but I have a and in fact this
is the way you know blocked your
networks are deployed that are deployed
over a gossip network where each member
is connected to some number logarithmic
is enough and so you pay by you know a
few hops probably no more than a
logarithmic number of hops to reach
everybody but I would capsulate all that
in a communication substrate and it's
the level of these algorism I would just
say okay there's in caste and broadcasts
and how it's implemented is probably its
own kind of module I wouldn't change the
fundamentals of the protocol it would
just change the way it's implemented I
don't see any reason to build this into
protocols
I mean the trade-off would be that I
cannot make any fault tolerance or any
resilience guarantees under these models
that are resilient to resilient against
a very adaptive adversary these will not
this will be probabilistic assumptions
right by by assumption yes right right
so from a theory point of view yes there
are protocols to do that and they're
very interesting from a practical point
of view I have yet to see a system you
know even of thousands of endpoints
where this is really a problem you know
sending a few thousand messages for one
node that's not so good assumption but
yeah
it's a good point and there are a lot of
advances in the last one or two years
also in the randomized protocols arena
those are really also very accelerated
in the last year three years because we
cut before the protocols were
polynomials with a fairly kind of an
attractive degree and they were also
complex and I really want to emphasize I
kind of have two hats here the the
engineering hat and the Theory has I
really want to emphasize the right side
here if you want to give a very very
complex theoretical protocol for
engineers to build and maintain and
debug and trust the world economy or you
know financial services on it good luck
they really need something very very
robust and the simpler the more robust
the implementation is
so in this arena and this again is the
wisdom that holds not just in the
blockchain and Byzantine world but also
in the crash model and underlies all of
our you know data center storage systems
Cassandra all of them you know and all
of them based on taxes or view Stanford
education or Etsy Dior is looking for
you know all these systems design you
know for standard benign failures the
primary backup intuition seem to be the
simplest where really everything is
driven by one primary replicating state
or commands to the backups and that does
seem to be the simplest core
unfortunately a leader based or a
primary based protocol is inherently not
randomized herbal and not not
asynchronous so you need to timeout
because you're waiting for this leader
what are you gonna do you need to apply
timeout as soon as you're applying
timeout it's not around a sinker purely
asynchronous protocol it's not
symmetrical this is not a theoretical
kind of a rigorous answer this is my
best intuition from dealing with
reliable systems for twenty years
they're all ability and their primary
backup paradigm and that's the simplest
way to drive these I don't know does
anybody else have opinions on it all
right let's see I have a few minutes
I want to say anything out of the
flexibility
work so let me just kind of advertise an
approach that really goes beyond so I
kind of spent an hour almost an hour
talking about the journey of four
decades of Byzantine fault-tolerance its
relevance to blockchains
some of the vision very ambitious and
very compelling vision that we have in
this field and that Libra is you know is
now promoting in sort of what I won't
have time today is to talk about okay
but what what do we do when something
goes wrong I mean these are technologies
that are going to drive very very
serious services just like the
spacecraft you know mission critical
setting this is going to be mission
critical but at scale and it's far more
adversarial situations and you know the
wild Internet so where are these
assumptions they're really nice for
writing theory papers no more than a
third are faulty you know synchronous
asynchronous all of this what happens
when something does go wrong this is
what keeps us up at night can we go
beyond the current approaches and
current resilience pounds and current
limitations not just in terms of
resilience and scalability but also in
terms of safety and the answer is yes
and so in a paper that's about to be
presented next week at IC MCCS we're
talking about flexible visiting fault
tolerance and the approach has two
ingredients one is the introduction of a
new fault model that allows us not to
break any impossibility results we don't
do that we don't violate but to bypass
them and really go higher than any known
resilience balanced both in the
synchronous and in the secret
asynchronous setting and combined and
how do we do this so we do this by
looking at the failure model and
realizing that it's perhaps not always
relevant to think about the same failure
model that you know NASA used when it
designed a control system for its
avionics control and in particular
Byzantine failures which capture the
worst case failures are not really the
worst case and are not really what we
want to always necessarily design for so
when we're talking about block chains
operating in a Association of a hundred
of some of the strongest companies in
the industries these are companies that
operate services 24/7 they do not crash
they do not becoming unavailable maybe
even some synchrony can be guaranteed
certainly if I say a message will arrive
within 10 days that seems like a
synchronous bound that will be hard to
break in these systems at the same time
what we do know that happens in these
systems is first of all there's huge
economical incentive to cheat now
because these will be the platforms and
the basis of financial services secondly
any systems that's deployed online
almost out there has been at some point
broken and secrets were stolen or
sometimes it's an insider attack so
sometimes what you have is that secrets
or keys may get compromised but the
systems will not so all that means is
that liveness is not so much a problem
ok it's actually the easy part is to
guarantee aliveness but guaranteeing
safety and security is the difficult
part once you have that resolution and
break away from the assumption that
crash is the worst thing that can happen
to you and you know prevent progress
then you you can get stronger resilience
bounce and again combine synchrony in a
synchrony and the second thing that you
realize is that systems were built with
single design point in mind so you pick
synchronous asynchronous or you pick
randomizer and then you know you pick
one of these parameters and that's it
the system is fixed but in a real
setting we may want more diversity in
our approach for example there may be
transactions that are $5 coffee at the
Starbucks that we don't need extremely
paranoid assurance levels for and then
there are transactions that are I don't
know buying or selling a house that we
need higher assurance for we may want to
change our assumptions based on what we
observe in the network if the network is
under attack they may want to may want
to change and adjust our assurance
levels so this is the diversity that we
build in the mechanism and so we
flexible Byzantine fault tolerance we
are able to do both are available to in
one solution bring stronger resilience
as well as diverse diversified assurance
levels and unfortunately I won't have
time to talk about any of it today but
let me just say that flexible BFT is a
joint work with a car Technic and Ling
Ren who are my postdocs at humor
research and finish off with what I've
started sort of say the main takeaway is
there's still a lot a lot of attention
and a lot of Drive where companies
enterprises romance federal banks
they're all going to the experts and I
want to advance this technology and we
at Calibra are committed to advancing
the technology and to working on the
challenges and opportunities that still
remain we're also hiring and with this
well thank you
[Applause]
more questions this was a very good
discussion I really appreciate it yep
yeah so let me just flush maybe one
slide about the model so the way you
know one of the ingredients in in this
flexible approach is what we call alive
but corrupt faults or in short it's ABC
fault
and what this models is you know
situations like the one you are talking
about Joffe but also like the one where
your keys are stolen
so you're still up you're participating
in protocol you're not gonna prove 8a
prevent progress by not participating
but there's also a hacker out there that
has your keys and might try to rush and
send messages on your behalf or cheat or
you know double spend the balance that
you have so all of these scenarios are
modeled by ABC alive but corrupt
failures where crashes are actually the
more severe type of failures that we
don't expect to happen okay availability
is guaranteed but corruption you know
this this any behavior that deviates
from the prescribed protocol is expected
to happen and with ABC faults you can
break away from these known
zillions pounds yes so again think of a
situation area where your key your
secret key is stolen you're not gonna
stop because of that you you are still
contributing to the protocol you're
still participating but there might also
be a + tecar
that every once in a while will try to
pretend and send messages on your behalf
and to the rest of the network there's
no difference between you or your key so
your behavior looks corrupt but you're
not attacking the liveness of the
protocol you're only attacking the
safety of the protocol so these are ABC
failures yes precisely any other
ingredient since you're asking a risk
going through some of my talk anyway yep
up to 2/3 yeah so the other ingredient
is a completely new protocol which
removes any synchronous bounce from the
protocol so typical protocol like the
one you have on the left has you know
some some synchronous assumptions built
into the protocol and works in kind of
synchronous rounds and our protocol
which is also quite simple does not have
any steps that have synchronous bounce
in the protocol only the decision which
is concluded by by the observer of the
protocol that looks at the transcripts
of the protocol only that uses these
synchronous bounds
okay so there's there's no assumption
and no parameter built into the protocol
and the resilience bound or the singer's
synchronous bounce so to your question
Ally
just wanna maybe flesh out what
resilience pounds do we get so with a
particular choice of parameters in this
protocol what you can get is a
combination of Byzantine in total number
of corruptions that breaks away from the
normal bounds so with the normal bounds
so the gray area here is the number of
Byzantine protocol a number of Byzantine
faults and anything in the gray area is
impossible under this line because
obviously you cannot have total number
of faults that's less than the Byzantine
number of faults but usually for for
synchronous for acing on a solution what
you have is at most third and what you
get with a flexible B of T is for
synchronous assumptions if anybody waits
outside the protocol observes the
transcript of the protocol no single
protocol that solves for everybody by
February outside the protocol observes
and waits for you know whatever duration
it decides it can get to any combination
of this Green Square
so essentially what it gets is this
upper right corner there's no reason you
know there's no trade-off and for
asynchronous assumptions what you get is
this orange looking curve where the the
less Byzantine faults occur the higher
the total number of corruptions that you
can tolerate up to two-thirds and this
is with this particular choice of
parameters we can instantiate the
flexible PFT protocol with different
choices of parameters and then get these
trade-off curves you know with different
bounds here and the synchronous ones are
these points
maybe we should have I don't know any
informal chat about this at some point
Oh fine all right
[Applause]